hallo deutsch schule punkt ch hören und
nachsprechen lektion 55
hört zu und spricht nach
bei meinem job ist mir wichtig dass sich
mit menschen arbeiten kann
beim 1
bis mir wichtig dass sich mit menschen
arbeiten kann
am wichtigsten ist dass sich meine
arbeit gerne mache
mir ist wichtig dass sich viel geld
verdienen
1 nach
ist dass sich die ganze zeit bei der
arbeit sitze
ein
ist dass sich die ganze zeit bei der
arbeit sitze
ich finde gut dass sich selbstständig
arbeiten kann
ich finde gut dass sich selbständig
ich finde schlecht dass meine arbeit
monoton ist
ein vorteil am beruf flugbegleiterin ist
dass sie viele fremde länder
kennenlernen kann
vorteil und beruf flug
dass sich viele fremde länder
kennenlernen kann
positiv
beruf ist dass sich draußen arbeiten
kann
positiv
im beruf ist dass sich draußen arbeiten
kann
ich bin gerne gärtner weil ich draußen
arbeiten kann
ich habe heute gerne als lehrerin weil
ich mit kindern und jugendlichen
arbeiten kann
ich arbeite gerne als lehrerin weil ich
mit kindern und jugendlichen arbeiten
kann
ich wollte frisörin werden weil ich viel
kontakt mit menschen haben möchte
ich wollte frisörin
weil ich viel kontakt mit menschen haben
möchte
ich kündige meinen job weil ich einen
schlechten chef habe
ich kündige meinen
job weil ich einen schlechten chef habe
ich habe wenig zeit für meine familie
weil ich viel arbeiten muss
ich habe
zeit für meine familie weil ich viel
arbeiten muss
mir gefällt die aber
weil sie abwechslungsreich ist
mir gefällt die arbeit weil sie
abwechslungsreich ist
mein beruf macht mir spaß weil ich
selbstständig arbeiten kann
wenn ich den job bekomme werde ich viel
geld verdienen
wenn ich studiere
kann ich später viel geld verdienen
viel geld verdienen
wenn du koch werden möchtest musst du
eine berufslehre machen
wenn du koch wie
möchtest musst du eine berufslehre
machen
wenn du als an
arbeiten möchtest musst du an der
universität studieren
wenn du als anwalt arbeiten möchtest
musst du an der universität studieren
du wirst deinen job
wenn du oft zu spät zur arbeit kommt
du wirst deinen job verlieren wenn du
oft zu spät zur arbeit kommt
von allen jugendlichen beginnen eine
berufslehre wenn sie 16 jahre alt sind
70 prozent von allen jugendlichen
beginnen eine berufslehre wenn sie 16
jahre alt sind
der mechaniker die mechanikerin
der mechaniker die mechanikerin der
informatiker die informatikerin
der informatiker die informatikerin
der putzmann die putzfrau
der lehrer die lehrerin
der friseur die frisörin
der bauarbeiter die bearbeiterin
der pfleger die pflegerin
der sekretär diese kriterien
die
criteo diese kriterien
der polizist die polizistin
der
die ärztin
der arzt die ärztin
der kellner die kellnerin die rk
die kellnerin der koch die köchin der
koch die köchin
der verkauf
die verkäuferin der verkäufer die
verkäuferin
[Musik]